time travel don't work for black people
so imma choose you guys say Poltergeist
will call the Beast really and I'm
embarrassed and this normally doesn't
ever happen to me
hi I'm Brandon Scott Jones and I play
Isaac hi my name is Danielle Pinnock and
I play Alberta hello I'm Rebecca wasaki
and I play heady hi I'm Asher Groban and
I play Trevor T-money oh my God I'm Rose
McIver and I play Samantha arandakar I'm
a good car shambord car I played Jed hi
guys I'm Sheila Carrasco and I play
flowers hi I'm Roman Saragosa and I play
SAS office my name is Richie Moriarty I
play Pete
hi I'm Richie Moriarty and I play Pete
nope Dragon
I'm Devin Chandler long and I play
Dorset there you go there it is there it
is and we are here with BuzzFeed we're
doing a quiz to discover which ghost we
really are in real life first question
is which superpower would you love to
have
x-ray vision superhuman strength
invisibility time travel time travel yes
flight or reading Minds I don't know
about y'all but I grew up watching
Heroes and time travel has always been
my go-to I'm trying to decide
invisibility because my girl Alex Mack
if you ever seen that show back in the
day she used to go on her little group
and I'm a recluse so when people start
acting up I could be like YouTube about
I'm gonna go with reading Minds I know
you said that was about oh I think it's
a very good I think it's great because
here's the thing all those thoughts that
I have when people are like are they mad
at me I could just be like yes I am then
I would justify this question number two
choose a song to sing at karaoke as it
was by Harry Styles about damn time by
lizzo I want to dance with somebody by
Whitney Houston running up that hill by
Kate Bush
I want it that way by Backstreet Boys
and Since You've Been Gone by Kelly
Clarkson I want to dance with somebody
boom 100 I'm on board I'm
actually boys I'm Whitney all day every
day
[Music]
I want lizzo to play my great great
granddaughter on ghost love you lizzo
and you're not choosing a song listen I
know I know but since you since you've
been going
I'm choosing I want it that way because
I feel like anytime somebody sings that
song and karaoke everybody joins in and
that's like the best part of karaoke you
know what that's the best answer you
know it is
the best answer yeah
all right if I were to literally be like
you are
my fire I Wanna Dance
you've sadly died at Woodstone Manor
what exactly happened to you fell down a
flight of stairs allergic reaction to a
cookie slipped off a ladder crushed
under a chandelier locked in an old
Vault I really thought I could jump off
the roof yeah I like the final one yeah
that's pretty great I think we all had
that when I was a kid my parents were
terrified I was gonna jump off the roof
because I was obsessed with flying it
wasn't a roof jumper yeah
I would go with chandelier crushing I
want to go out in a unique way I'm
Columbus I would probably fall down a
flight of stairs a lot of these are very
interesting but I know that a cookie
will kill me what type of cookie no I
just I love cookies I love cookies
that's why that's what's going to get me
one fell down my answer is I really
thought I could jump off the roof oh
that's very interesting because I can
see B B being in
the state in which I might think that
that was possible honestly like Crush
under a chandelier because really that
is
fabulous way to go choose a ghost's
character to trust with a secret
Baylor Nigel Mark Stephanie crash uh one
of the cholera ghosts in the basement
who would I trust with a secret Nigel
I'm also gonna choose Nigel I might
choose Nigel oh yeah that's good I'm
doing Baylor because Pune Patel is my
best friend the answer is they're
absolutely available wait but
first you've ever told the person I've
told who knows that I see ghosts yeah I
think Baylor will be like all right sis
wait Rebecca could you pick Nigel Nigel
oh that makes it
you know I feel like Mark is pretty
trustworthy yeah Mark's your guy I would
probably go mark
all right Nigel
Poltergeist the sixth sense of
Beetlejuice do you guys say Poltergeist
or Poltergeist really yeah
I would have said Poltergeist really is
that how they say it no just me I really
wanted to say Beetle guys
it depends what kind of mood we're in
right now like tonight tonight right so
what are you feeling my first instinct
was Sixth Sense Haley Joel at his best I
he's done some cool things since but
no I I'm just Beetlejuice all the way
yeah
music
all day every day I've never seen Casper
I love watching new movies I'm watching
Casper Casper Devin Sawa come on y'all
can we get a little
uh my Lord we loved Evans
was it Bill Pullman or was it Jeff
Daniels bills who plays the Dad and
everything that's a trick question I
think Beetlejuice yeah juice too
I'm going with ghosts because of Whoopi
Goldberg ultimate brown he's just so
iconic
one of the best performers
just she's so funny in that she's
[Music]
I mean you've spoken about women
should we get Whoopi Goldberg to come
down
we'll be okay the next one which
inventive what stone Manor would you
want to attend prom a viking funeral
Halloween a dinner party Jay's D and D
night come on or just a night in at a TV
Marathon we're picking prom I really
love that episode
I'm picking a viking funeral because how
many times can you attend a viking
funeral
I'm going dinner party I love dinner oh
dinner party was fun I liked it we did
we
did
yeah
I'm gonna go just a night in in a TV
Marathon just to hang out selling Sunset
oh let me watch it together I was really
hoping to be at my dinner party well I'm
not gonna be okay anyone have prom with
me no no take it I almost went to prom
music I almost went to prom too but if
I'm honest about what my true desires
are yeah it's to sit around and be
snuggly on the couch I would go to that
prom if uh a question puts that tux back
up yeah finally pick something from
ghosts Pete's Trooper handbook the
Woodstone Manor Renovations Alberta's
music Trevor's pants Oscar the squirrel
a ghost getting sucked off oops ready to
pick try this pants so that I can give
him back to him and he can put them on
I'm gonna take a ghost getting [ __ ] up
okay but don't hit it yet okay I'm gonna
do Alberta's music just have to I'm
gonna go the Woodstone Manor don't look
at it though oh don't ready I'm gonna go
to Trevor's pants so um Rose can put
them back on guys I already have my
answer no I'm premature and I'm
embarrassed and this normally doesn't
ever happen to me uh you can tell us
wait wait wait hold on wait wait wait
don't do it I'm gonna take Alberta's
music
I'm gonna pick Oscar the squirrel
I was getting sucked up I'm sorry his
name's oscar but Oscar my dad's Oscar
I'm going Pete's Trooper handbook I have
to okay
two one click
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hold on where did I see in the
beginning I am Richie Moriarty
you were me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
September 29th
is fall when you're at home when it's
dark outside okay the trees are changing
the colors
everything's dying but you want to live
turn your TV on Thursday night
8 30.
CBS
we'll see you then
[Music]